when when I think of music today and
when I try to listen to music today I
hear a lot of words I don't want to hear
[Music]
please clarify what's an okay boomer oh
oh it's like a slide okay oh it just
kills me that you know someone who's 19
or something I got calluses that are 19
you know there's this assumption that we
don't know anything about anything and
I'm the first to admit I'm ignorant
about plenty in this world but I know a
couple of things about some other things
that I'm sure whoever said that doesn't
know either
wait till you get to our age and you
start looking back on people who are
that age you'll find out yeah I would be
this respect that I somewhat agree
because I'm new to the lingo but yeah I
mean nobody wants to be disrespected
yeah I guess it seems like as as soon as
they say okay boomer or any that trans
kind of voice it's like it's dismissive
I'm not offended because the people that
I use that work with or more or less in
my generation I'm offended if they
allude to okay old person okay double
AARP card carrier or something like that
cuz like I have to remind my son who's
45 like you're five years away from
carrying the double AARP card you know
okay blue
I don't feel comfortable asking anyone
for help I am NOT out the pasture yet I
feel very comfortable asking younger
people for help like especially on the
day when the knees not working right yes
I'm a developer so your programming
language isn't suffer that so yet the
younger guys I mean and and gals they
just pick up stuff so quick I think we
said you got to put the pride in the
drawer and ask if that person is 18 or
80 ask oh I so agree with that I mean I
have grandchildren who I love dearly but
what they do is that they guilt you and
what what happens is is that they feel
like they're entitled to these things
everything they know you want them to be
happy
and they know you want them to fit in
with everybody so what you gotta do
you're gonna go buy them that $1,200
cellphone after you just bought that
last cell phone six months ago that cost
you $1,000 that you still paying on that
I think that entitlement comes from
their upbringing
I think parenting has become more luxe
they've we've forgotten that we're
supposed to raise kids to guide them
along you're entitled to tell me how you
feel in your titled to tell me what do
you want to do and how can I help but
just to hand money endlessly for our
generation to do that shame on us I mean
I agree with a lot of that I think some
kids are you know they get $500 or
cellphones and stuff like this and
there's certain expectations but they're
in for a world of trouble and a lot of
stuff that were
gonna have to deal with because we'll be
dead what the climate is going to look
like you know maybe it's not such a
great thing to be that young this is the
oldest cliche I bet Mozart was telling
his father you know your music stunk but
yeah but still I mean I mean this
Lanka's yeah our music kicked ass when
when I think of music today and when I
try to listen to music today I hear a
lot of words I don't want to hear there
are a lot of lyrics about violence you
know the words in today's music and even
my kids agree is it's more direct and
lewd at the same time I mean I hear
they're for it and I think can you not
think of a better word is it speaks to a
lack of kriti creativity
I'm in the technology field so when I
grew up it's no cell phone you go to a
you go to a payphone and you got to have
the you know the right coin and then so
the convenience is amazing cell phones
weren't necessary when I was growing up
because we got along just fine mama
found you and she wanted to find you
daddy did too you know we knew the times
we had to be in the house we knew where
we could go and where we couldn't go and
wouldn't like I said what mama wanted to
she found you there were long periods of
time especially in the summer when
nobody knew where we were my mother and
my father had no idea where we were and
there was no way to get in touch with us
or then and that was just the way I
liked it that's hard for me it's like
you take a cell phone the school it's
such a distraction for them I think
there's a lot of challenges now with
kids and even young adults with cell
phones and I'm glad we didn't have them
when I was coming up I do not agree that
just because you disagree with this
person you suddenly have a right to go
beat on it and that's what I've seen
because that community suffers more
violence than any other community out
there that needs to stop this is
something that's gotten way better
during our lifetimes they think the cops
used to boss gay bars they used to
arrest these guys they got people got
beaten up they're still getting beaten
up but we've come a long way are we
there yet no but how could you not like
this progress I mean we live in America
right so live and let live you know no
problem just yeah live any way you like
camping just don't infringe on other
people's rights kind of thing don't try
to force right you're right over other
people's rights you know adding to that
is you know in particularly the women
and men's bathroom I you know I think
about my kids
and this gender-neutral bathrooms just
bothering me I'm glad my kids are all
grown up but it's not safe from my
growing up you you didn't go outside the
community for help
I mean you sucked it up and you did it
you know you didn't like it so what I
somewhat agree with it now because I'm
seeing all of this homelessness I'm
seeing all of the people out on the
street with all of the problems and I'm
thinking to myself yeah there has to be
something better you know then suck it
up and figure it out I grew up in what
is now South LA there was domestic
violence there was a lot going on then
but you did you kind of sucked it up and
in sucking it up you kind of passed it
on to your general the next generation
because no one ever dealt with it and a
lot of like for example domestic
violence it was like the norm
I think our generation with the culture
it's like we don't want people to think
that there's something wrong with us so
we're not going to go and try to get it
fixed
I thought this is just an age thing I
mean people of a certain amount of
experience in age have always run the
world kids don't know enough about the
world super old people don't have the
energy to run the world so this is who
runs the world at no time in the history
of our country have we had the quantity
of people under 35 years of age who are
CEOs millionaires and billionaires
people who came from literally no silver
spoon and then now a couple years later
they could buy fifty billion dollar
homes at multiple locations and pay cash
to me I think that's awesome Mike you're
just mad because you can't sell
mortgages the people quote-unquote in
power which is the government mostly
baby boomers you know look at the
Democratic field look at the whose
president right now and they're all
pretty old but like like Mike said the
guys with the money it's the younger
guys and it's always the money that
drives politics too you know this is
LeFort so yeah so there is the behind
the scene power that you know some
people may know the boomers are getting
tired I believe that we've made the
world a better place and I look toward
civil rights as being my mark I remember
not being able to go to certain cafes I
I remember the bus situations so we
fought very very hard for civil rights
so all the rights that people are
getting nowadays they're getting those
rights because we fought for them we
March we boycotted
we thought we went to jail we had our
churches bombed we did all of this so
when someone asked us well what do you
think
about LGBTQ rights we can say yeah I
think they're entitled to their rights
you know that was part of the civil
rights movement where we didn't only
fight for rights for black people
African Americans we fought for rights
for everyone so I think that yeah well
we've left our mark when we leave the
earth I think one thing that hopefully
were gonna be remembered for Lady
Thatcher Pope John Paul and Ronald
Reagan freed over a hundred million
people from communism I agree with most
of that not what Mike said I grid with
none of that we made some great strides
with made some great strides with civil
rights and absolutely I don't disagree
with any of that but at the same time
this generation has turned a blind eye
to some serious environmental issues
we've killed huge swathes of the ocean
the polar caps are melting there used to
be a middle class when we were young
there was a middle class in the 60s it's
moving its way out to the edges now
there's a lot of poor people and there's
a lot of really rich people and our
generation has to bear some
responsibility for some of that stuff
[Applause]
my wife goes for her censorship
interview Friday as from
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]